oh here we go yen so yeah against my
better judgment I'm gonna kind of do a
follow-up to the video I made a little
while back talking about channel awesome
which you might find add to be a
slightly odd thing because well nobody's
really talking about channel awesome
anymore in fact I it's probably a safe
guess that there's a fair number of
people out there who if you're watching
this video at all you might have seen it
gone up and thought wait has something
else happened did they do something else
stupid and think so and no they haven't
done anything else dumb but that's kind
of the point I want to talk about how
the channel seems to have survived and
whether what's going on or at least to a
degree I think there is still some
lasting impact to this and possibly some
more we'll see down the line that it
doesn't really seem to be getting talked
about anymore because the bulk of the
the controversy is kind of passed or
well I don't know if it's passed but it
doesn't seem to be building on itself
anymore the dominoes seem to have more
or less stopped falling so quick recap
channel awesome home of the nostalgia
critic got themselves into quite a bit
of hot water when there was a seventy
three page document put out basically
compiling the negative experiences of a
fairly large number of past and current
contributors to the channel awesome
website so in the wake of that channel
Austin put out two responses the first
response that they put out was a
complete non apology
using the phrase we regret that you felt
that way which obviously did not go over
well and then when they put out a second
response it was poorly put together it
was an it was supposedly an attempt to
pick apart some of the specific
complaints and only just a handful of
the things in the document and those it
didn't even address well and the fallout
from that had been even worse so nearly
all of the contributors who were not
direct channel awesome employees
all left the site because channel
awesome has its own in-house production
staff you know they they have their own
studio and their own stuff that they
make
but what channel awesome had been as a
site was an aggregate for a lot of
similarly themed and toned review
creators and all of them except two left
the only two remaining being guru guru
Larry and the cinema snob and they and
they look like they're not ever gonna
leave from the look of things in the
case of the cinema stop from from what I
understand he has a very strong sense of
loyalty to to channel awesome and
probably to the Walker brothers whereas
guru Larry just doesn't seem to really
give a crap I don't know him I don't
know a heck of a lot about but things
seem to have settled back to normal pace
in fact if you were to look at the
channel awesome YouTube page you might
just find yourself going oh did they
take a hiatus for a little while I can
see there was a gap and uploads but
they're pretty much back to daily
uploads again and more importantly
clearly of stuff that is now newly
produced there was a little bit of time
where first of all like nothing went up
and then just a normal episode of a
nostalgia critic went up and that was
something that was very obviously
filming and filmed in advance so it
wasn't clear for a little while if they
were just burning off whatever they had
already finished making and then it was
it was hard to know what was gonna
happen but new stuff started going up
there very obviously had been made
recently Doug and Rob put up their
sibling rivalry review of infinity war
there was more Tamra's never seen and
also Tamra just saw and so on all of
which and none of which I've seen I know
that they're there because I brought
into channel awesomes main page I have
not Reese absque Ribe die don't intend
to I'm not gonna say I never will but I
don't feel like the issues were ever
properly addressed which honestly is
probably why they're gonna keep going
and they're going to be moral
s'okay because what was interesting was
I think after that second response
especially which went down disastrously
there was a real expectation about what
have they gonna do next to try and fix
this and there was even indication from
I think it was Malcolm ray who's one of
their actors that indicated that they
were either were preparing or had shot
and were working on editing a response
video in addition to the response
statement that they put out that never
materialized
and I think maybe what happened it was
that I was gonna say cooler heads
prevailed maybe they just realized that
there was no way to put out this fire
actively they didn't have the the means
to do so and unless they were going to
basically come crawling on hands and
knees going we're sorry we're sorry
we're sorry here's everything that we
did wrong and here's how we're gonna
change if they weren't gonna do that
which clearly they weren't for whatever
reason then the best thing they could do
at that point would just be to shut up
which is what they did and because at
that point they're not their failure to
put out a third response or a video
response isn't going to win them back
any of the support subscribers etc that
they lost and they did lose quite a few
they took a decent hit you know tens of
thousands of subscribers gone and that
hasn't really started bouncing back yet
they've been sitting at 1 million 16,000
for a couple of weeks now with no real
growth so far as I could tell but they
also haven't hemorrhaged any more
subscribers so they're not winning back
anyone new but they're not losing anyone
else either and that was probably the
smartest thing that they could do
because if they were either unwilling or
unable
to offer a maiya culpa and possibly
offer up a scapegoat you know someone
who they could specifically lay blame on
then probably the smartest thing that
they could do was just to shut up and
move forward and not address it anymore
so as to keep whoever hadn't already
left and when I say that was the best
thing to do I'm not saying morally
morally it would have been nice to get
to see an actual like proper addressing
respectful at least addressing of the
issues that wasn't as dismissive and
spiteful and ill-conceived as their
initial one was but from a business
standpoint certainly just keeping my
mouth shut that was the that was the
smart move so channel awesome lives sort
of because channel awesome really at
this point is kind of two things
there's the YouTube channel which I
would say actually a fair amount of
people are subscribed to and don't even
realize the channel awesome is kind of
or was until recently kind of its own
thing separate as as its own entity as a
website and then there is that website
there is the channel awesome website now
the channel awesome YouTube is gonna be
okay and it is come early okay it's
gonna be fine
they like I said they haven't
hemorrhaged more subscribers they're not
gaining more back but they're not losing
any their views seem to be decent
they've they've gotten back to their
once a day output that they were at
previously so that all seems to be fine
so that's gonna keep plugging forward
channel awesome the website is kind of a
ghost town because there were there were
a few well there's there were basically
two primary reasons as far as users
going to it for the reasons for Channel
awesome to exist one was for the active
community because they had a forum that
allowed
you know communication between fans
communication from with fans with
creators with that real direct
connection that's gone the forums are
closed down and shut off and then the
other thing was it was an aggregate of
all this like I said before similarly
themed and sort of similarly toned
review content so if you like to that
sort of thing this was basically a
one-stop shop to find a whole bunch of
people who did that kind of thing and
who sometimes interacted with eachother
crossed over between shows so that was
nifty like to have a one-stop shop for a
certain type and style of humorously
themed review of a wide variety of stuff
it doesn't really work as that anymore
either because like I said they you know
they had dozens of contributing partners
and now they're all gone but - so
there's very little reason for anyone to
go to the channel awesome website
because there's only three guys on it
all three of whom have their own YouTube
channels so you might as well just
subscribe to three channels and not even
bother with this site so Channel awesome
the site I'm not gonna say it's dead yet
but for my money and I'm not I say for
my money I'm not gonna bet money on this
but I would think that within the next
six months one of two things happens
either they start courting new
contributing partners hoping that things
have died down enough that they can
bring in people who either don't care
about the controversy or figure the
controversy has been quiet for long
enough that they can safely get a bump
from Channel awesome and being
associated with them won't be a
detriment
so they'll either start trying to
rebuild a contributor base or the site
will just die and I'm not sure you know
when I say within six months I'm not
necessarily saying they'll just pull the
plug and it'll
gone but I think it'll become clear that
if it's just continuing to basically be
them notifying whenever there's an
upload from the three contributors from
the two extra contributors and channel
awesome itself that are left that it's
just going to be quietly left to die on
the vine and the I think the one big
x-factor in this is it's not clear how
much of channel awesomes revenue was
generated through the website as opposed
to the YouTube channel because obviously
they get you know stuff off the YouTube
channel they get you know they have ads
placed there they've done I think spawn
yeah they've done sponsorships of
certain videos and so forth so they're
getting revenue that way but you know
even if you've got really good view and
subscriber numbers obviously way better
than I do YouTube as a source of income
is really erratic it you know from day
to day month to month it can go up and
down it's really hard to build a stable
business off of YouTube alone because
knowing what you're gonna be bringing in
month to month is really hard to track
out so it what may end up causing some
disruption for this channel in the long
run is how much of their stability was
owed to the primary website you know
through possibly add space sold on the
site through merchandise sold sold
through the shop on that side I believe
the shop is also currently closed down
on there so with that gone the question
becomes does the YouTube revenue is that
enough to maintain the rather sizeable
resources that channel awesome brags a
studio you know a guy dedicated to
making costumes and props to actors
including a sag member you know and
whatever and all their equipment is the
YouTube channel
enough to pay for all that I don't know
it might be it might not be though and I
wouldn't be shocked if in the next few
months to a year certain things or
features of some of the I was gonna say
less popular I just go with less view
because obviously you know people like
what they like and I'm sure these things
have their fans but some of the some of
the lower viewed ends of the things that
aren't made by say the walkers
themselves might start leaving I start
not being on the on the YouTube channel
anymore things like the orbit report or
the the top five lists I figure every
year Tamra will will stick around with
her stuff because they get they get
double duty out of her cuz she as she
you know they employ her as an actress
for when they do sketch stuff and she
also you know has her own stuff going on
Malcolm ray is pretty central to to
their to their cast but I wouldn't be
surprised if they start trimming their
their employee roles in a few months
depending on how much of that sort of
revenue stabilization came from the
channel awesome website which honestly
right now I cannot imagine is doing much
for them I mean I don't know what they
pay for the for the domain and and you
know whatever bandwidth they need to run
the thing but I can't have ahead I may
have best they got to be running neutral
at the at this point so it's been an
interesting thing and as I said people
kind of dropped off talking about it
because there was there wasn't a new
staggering revelation there wasn't a new
dumb thing that they did they put their
heads down and they kept quiet and the
world moved on and like I said I don't
I think the people that they've lost are
gonna stay lost just because they wanted
changed I mean that was the hashtag
changed the channel change didn't really
happen so why would they come back but I
think once the guys that channel awesome
knew that they again either weren't able
or weren't willing to placate the people
who are upset that they were better off
not responding it because they were just
taking off more people by doing that so
you know they gave up they gave up on
the people who they figure they're never
going to get back and work on keeping
whoever's left which numerically at
least as far as their subscriber numbers
on YouTube go is the majority of people
now it may not be the majority of active
people again just using myself as a
baseline you know I have 15,000
subscribers but there's a couple of
hundred who are super active who seem to
really watch nearly everything I put out
and who comment regularly so I think
it's still gonna be a bit of a hit to
them because they've probably lost some
of their most active supporters because
those were probably the people who were
hurt the most and I think the one last
thing I'll mention before I wrap it up I
saw somebody ask why did this turn into
such a big deal when Logan Paul didn't
even really lose any subscribers with
his whole mess and I think the answer to
that is when the Logan Paul thing
happened that was an outrage that was
primarily centered outside of his
subscriber base outside of his fan base
that made national news the outrage was
people who never even heard of this guy
before going wait what and that was
where the gang that's where most of the
anger was coming from
his fans didn't seem to be the ones who
were ticked off they seemed a little bit
off put confused but then he put out his
video and whether or not you feel it was
manufactured or genuine it was an
apology which allowed for you know any
fans who were questions you go oh well
he was sorry and to just stay with
channel awesome it was different because
the people who were upset were the fans
with Logan Paul the the controversy and
the real outrage was people who weren't
watching him with channel awesome the
anger came from people who loved this
site you know contributors to it and
then it just it upset the people who
were the supporters so it did the the
impact was greater in terms of
subscriber loss it did the controversy
did last longer because the people they
ticked off wasn't you know these outside
forces who are like channel awesome
what's that what did they do
Oh awful no they were people like oh my
god channel awesome but I love that site
and what happened and they were the ones
who were upset so I I think I think
that's where the difference was and I
think that's why this one had at this
particular I guess YouTube channel
controversy had a longer shelf life than
these things usually do because these
things usually done in a week two weeks
top this one went months but it seems to
be done now and channel awesome seems to
have survived for now for the most part
at least as a YouTube entity like I said
the the main site seems to be pretty
much toast so unless they can figure out
something else to do with it I can't
imagine that that's really gonna be much
for them anymore but I just kind of
wanted to touch on this again because I
had some just had some thoughts and
those things yeah
you know it seems like it's done and
they probably did the smartest thing at
least you know since they weren't gonna
do what everyone wanted them to do so I
suppose that'll wrap it up my thoughts
on channel awesome and unless something
else major happens probably the last
time I'll ever talk about it so that's
me what are your thoughts on all this
whatever your they are drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
if you like the show you can support me
on patreon and you can also follow me on
Twitter and I do a podcast with my
partner called punch like your girl you
can buy t-shirts there's links for all
this stuff down in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]